create an environment where we thrive
what's up believe nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the one rule
series because I watch a lot of top 10
videos we make a lot of content and some
of the rules repeat themselves over and
over and over again and so the aim with
this series is it takes some of the most
popular rules that keep coming up and
smoosh them together into one video for
you so today we're gonna learn how to
create an environment for success enjoy
[Music]
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think
I'm a bit more as strategy what's your
strategy in life somebody asked me on
Instagram after I posted a scary if the
mindset has been skewed how can you
bring it back and I answered with by
surrounding yourself with people who
have the mindset you aspire to my
friends please understand that mindset
is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple now
it's very hard to cut people with
pessimism cynicism and negativity when
they are the people that are the closest
to you parents siblings spouse but the
bottom line is if you're asking the
question I'm gonna give you the answer
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offence and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume and
with whom you consume it I work hard
that well more than 50% of the people in
this audience are here today because
they worry about the way they would be
judged by one and/or two family members
in their you know seven eight people
circle if you're not feeling it find new
friends I'm being dead serious about
this this one is real big for me who you
hang out with is a huge Yannick and
these are all trying true things right
we've heard the you're the whatever of
the five friends you spent like that's
real and one new winner friend like you
know what I mean had one new winner
friend and cut one loser friend like
yeah I know he's been your boy since
fourth grade but he sits at home and
smokes weed and plays 2k all day like
you can only love them so much
so for me my three e's are element
environment and energy every one has an
element that they thrive in if you take
someone out of it their element they
won't be the same a modern-day example
would be Michael Jordan he was
incredible at basketball you took him
out a basket will put him into baseball
no one remembers his career we're
talking about one of the best athletes
of all time your environment is the
environment around you you can take a
fish out of water and give it a
beautiful mansion and a Bentley
and all the money in the world but it
would die and that's what we are like
our environment everyone is an
environment which they thrive which we
have to craft your boss if you're at
work is never gonna ask you what
environment you succeed in right like
that never happens so we have to create
an environment where we thrive and then
finally its energy we some of us love
high energy environments high pressure
some of us succeed in lower energy
environments and low pressure figuring
out your energy and the frequency on
which you operate best will help you
thrive as well so for me those are the
three e's to really create thriving
environment know your element know your
environment and know your energy and so
on all times if I see anything going
wrong I'm going is my element out of
alignment is my environment out of
alignment or is my energy out of
alignment and that's a great three
question test you can do to yourself
when you don't think things are going
right and all you have to do is bring
that back into alignment so you know
every time I'm having trouble every time
I'm like men
think I can get to where I'm going I
just started looking at the top I don't
look at the bad facts all I do is I
start searching
tell me about wealthy people facts about
wealthy people anything what are they
doing what do they buy it just gets me
out of my problem right it gets me to
think bigger you know the first plane I
bought I bought this plane because I saw
other wealthy people making moves I'm
not an irresponsible person okay like
I've always been a very frugal person
but the frugal was hurting me not
helping me your network is your net
worth how rich you can get has something
to do with who you're hanging with how
rich you can think has something to do
with you who you're hanging with okay
how smart you are has something to do
with your surroundings if you hang out
with dumb people you gonna end up dumb
if you hang out with junkies you're
gonna end up being a junkie you hang out
with criminals I'm not talking about two
people that go to jail I'm talking about
all the people it's your office right
now they cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with creme
crimps you end up being a Crim if you
want to build a network number one thing
commit to building a network a network
by definition is not if you're building
a new it network it's not the people
you're already with it's how do I add
people to my network so number one you
got to commit to building a network
number two who do you want in the
network who is it
most of you just go for more people like
you have already in your network I want
new people new characters new
personalities new thinking new ideas
the old adage if you're the smartest
person in the room you in the wrong room
and number three when you start building
this network up and you start meeting
the people okay number two is who do you
want to meet who who you and add to the
Met Network you go in at nine thousand
people in a room you don't need to meet
all nine thousand you need to meet maybe
a list of 30 or 40 people who do you
want to meet number three when you meet
them focus on them not on you it
shouldn't be here's my card
I'm
chiropractor this is what I do can I
give you an adjustment it it should be
like who are you how can I help you what
are you doing where do you live okay
what projects are you working on how can
I help you if you go into politics you
should go to DC if you go into finance
New York movies probably still LA and
untuk is Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
has an aspect that's that's very open
very fluid and and it helps tremendously
on these cutting-edge ideas you want to
be in the place where you can talk to as
many people as possible about your ideas
on because that's the way you will know
that they're cutting edge and you will
improve them even more the environment
that you're in matters the people that
you're around matters if the physical
environment that you're in matters if
the sounds that are happening matter and
so when you are working or when you're
in work mode what are you listening to
what's on what's what sounds are coming
out what's on your walls around you or
your an environment that makes you come
alive that makes you want to think
bigger when I'm at my office I have
these posters on the wall of people who
inspire me for different reasons five
different people who inspire me for
different messages and different reasons
I walk into they're like this is it I
got to do something big today right and
those five people may mean nothing to
you that's okay it means something to me
it helps me believe more and so creating
that physical environment for yourself
you know a lot of people will say well I
don't have the money to have a private
island because the private island is
gonna be the thing that makes me come
alive right you can have a picture of a
private island you can get the feeling
of a private island you know it doesn't
have to cost a lot of money to create an
amazing environment for yourself think
about the friends that you're hanging
around with thinking about the videos
that you watch and the things that you
consume right are you are you going on
YouTube and watching prank videos or
you're going on YouTube and watching
videos like this where you get to be
motivated and inspired and learn
something
having that built in so you have a great
environment that sets you up for success
and reinforces a success all the time
it's hardly an entrepreneur's we don't
have a boss there's nobody saying why
are you on Facebook right now right
there's nobody saying why are you
answering those snaps and on Instagram
and just texting people why are you not
working right that's what a boss would
do we are our own boss and there's a
great freedom in that right there's an
amazing freedom but it's part of the
reason why
maybe you wanted to start your own
business but there's also a lack of
accountability and so you want to have
an environment to hold you accountable
when I'm working and then I look up and
I see Steve Jobs looking back at me it's
like get back to work and keep working
hustle hustle harder go when I'm
watching the videos and doing the
research for the videos into this
channel it reinforces it like all these
successful people are telling me
everyday you gotta work harder you got
to push better you got to learn more you
got to you know it just inspires me to
want to keep doing my absolute best and
they hold me accountable my environment
holds me accountable because I don't
have a boss in my business so you need
to create an environment that is
designed for your success you know
Lionel articulates this really
beautifully and is a huge advocate of
having fun at work you're on these
things for two years do you really not
want to have fun on this is our lives
this is what we spend all of our time
doing so let's embrace it and have the
best time we can
I Love You Man
I haven't been home at all in seven
months and one must create a family
wherever you can and that's what we did
here just to be part of guys gang to be
surrounded by good people hard-working
people and that's nice it's been nice or
formed genuinely firm friendships would
it cost a lot of qualified first and
foremost become really good friends and
sort of second to that is the creative
relationship that we have you just out
in this gorgeous place and with each
other the whole time and ideas would
come up over dinner around the campfire
at night and we talked about a/c and
that's been an amazing lesson working
with guy and Lionel is that it also
seems to be that the best work comes out
the more fun you're having it's always a
gamble that casting thing you know and
did they in fact they do this crazy
thing now for more from Boys & Girls
easy this kind of chemistry testing with
like that's the most absurd thing in the
world to me that how can you manufacture
that it's it's some weird alchemy you
can't it's just there it isn't there and
we just you know it was the same for me
we went for dinner I happened that I
myself my wife or obsessed with the fall
at the time and I was like you know I
did such an incredible job and I loved
that show and then we just met and and
and it just seemed to work and it's a
similar sense of humor and a similar
approach to work as Jamie said and you
know I forgot I mean I forgot how how
intense that film is and we forgot like
it's it doesn't really let up but - so
we have do we have - the three of us I
think together we managed to make the
atmosphere on set
you know quite quite an enjoyable one
despite everything else and anything
again it's TaShawn Testament you know
that it's the wrong word which one
should take the credit for the fact you
know there was families around and it
was a very very lovely environment to
work in and then we we had fun and I
think you have to do you're lucky to be
working or looking to be working on such
a good project and you you know you
can't go around all sort of sad and
intense you
it's gotta be gonna get through the day
vote was my first job and I was very
very lucky to have a job there
everything I've learned a lot of my
training my eye my background has come
from my years of voc and I think working
for Ralph Lauren was a privilege in all
honesty when you work for a man that's
so decisive so consistent so brilliant
it's bound to or hopefully to influence
how you view your own career and so I
was very fortunate to have two really
great careers of both of these
institutions there was this one instance
that changed the way I viewed life when
my friend was 17 I was 16 and I get a
chance to go play for this big house you
know in Texas out in the country and
it's Christmas time mm-hmm when I get
there not gonna do any guy open the door
what's going on here I said what sir I'm
here to play for your uh your Christmas
party then why are two of you here
I said what you know he drove I didn't
have a you know license so you know I
said sure a problem he says yeah I can't
have two [ __ ] in my house at the same
time no mind you I've heard that word
said to me so much it didn't bother like
well okay well listen Ken can he just
wait in the drive well he said he can't
wait on this street and they look it
starts at 6:30 make up your mind so I
told my boy to come back at 8:15 8:30
which was late for us at that time and
he says hey where's your tuxedo I said
they didn't tell us to get one he says
well come on in this room and he took me
on a walk-in closet now look why doesn't
that got his clothes in his bedroom yeah
but he gave me two I don't know if y'all
remember the Brooks Brothers suit yet
patches I said wow I got the suede so as
I'm playing as I'm playing oh boy as I'm
playing right they're doing black jokes
you know you can marry them doing J
they're doing jumping they go oh man we
just funnin come on now we just phoning
it in and so I'm just playing but the
reason that I was calm is because my
grandmother taught me something called
furniture since she worked you know as a
mage he says you know then the word is
furniture whenever they're doing
whatever they're doing
you're just furniture you don't respond
and then the lady of the house is I
apologize for what's going on here could
you sing us something a song I said cool
chestnuts roasting no no fine okay and
the guy says hey man I like that right
then afterwards he gave me a hundred
bucks yeah at night necessary yeah
hundred call me [ __ ] every day but I
remember about to give him the jacket
back he says I can't wear that anymore
and then he made me wait outside up the
street and that night when Chris who by
the way he was my best friend who
actually lives at my house now when he
picked me up I said listen I gotta get
out of here I gotta get out of this
place because I'm too smart for what's
going on right now and either I'm gonna
hurt somebody or someone's gonna hurt me
because eventually I can't take too much
more of of that in the nest when I
decided to go to college in San Diego so
this is my working space I've been using
a walking desk for the last three or
four months now I'm not sure how much it
does for me but I'm sure it's healthier
than just sit down I'm also trying to
keep my desk clean because if you pan
over to my old desk which I don't
actually use anymore because it got so
filled with crap I don't know what to do
about this anymore I need to burn it
down something I used to work night
times but then I got kids and the kids
go to school and that means that we had
to wake up at 7:30 or so to take the
kids to school it's not exactly a
nine-to-five job but it is actually
fairly close and you can see that in in
the commit blocks it's interesting I've
sometimes do statistics of how which
time zones people are and what what time
people are working at and these days you
can definitely tell that a lot of people
are actually keeping pretty regular
hours I'm not the only one with kids
clearly
it's set at a very slow speed I call you
my zombie shuffling desk because if I
put it out any faster than one mile an
hour my mouse movements get very erratic
and I no longer can close my windows
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Leo Bob out there talking about how
to create an inspiring environment but
before that I want to know what is the
biggest change that you need to make in
your environment right now to allow it
to get you to where you want to go
what's the single biggest thing that you
need to change I want you to leave down
the comments below when you write it
down you're much more likely to actually
take action on it so leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip if
you have a group around this habit
change all of a sudden you now have a
whole different environment that gives
you a different feedback system so if
you're going if you say you tell your
group and the Sassi my group of people
that you actually care about their
opinion because otherwise should just
forget about it but if you care about
their opinion now let's say it's five to
ten people and you say I am going to
write every day before I check email or
I pay ten thousand dollars right if you
stole people better than that you would
definitely do it or you know you know
I'm done where I'd like we'd get a pie
in my face if I didn't stick to it yes
things like that donate to you know the
political party you don't like yeah are
you gonna have to eat some
factory-farmed meat or something
something you definitely don't do now I
do yeah I actually went for my book I
you know you know I'm gonna I promise
you and some other friends that I would
eat a beef burger veggie burger if I
didn't have his book done by the end of
the year yeah and so I was motivated to
get up and start writing
but anyway so commit to this group
create a consequence that you definitely
are not going to - you know you don't
want to have and you're definitely not
gonna
and so when you do the habit you think
the positive benefit of getting to
report back to them and even as you do
the heavier thing you know I get to tell
Corbett that I'm gonna do this yep I did
this and so that's positive feedback for
doing it and then if you didn't do it
you have negative feedback and have to
tell your group that I didn't do it and
that would be shameful and you don't
want look bad in the eyes of your peers
and you probably have to you know eat
the burger or get the pie in the face
and so you wouldn't want to do that so
now you've just reversed the feedback
loop with a very simple change in your
environment the most important work ever
if you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple so it would be to like a little
beacon pay believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]